Major breaking news. Donald Trump's
administration has done it again,
advancing the right to keep and bear
arms. This time, the Secretary of War
Pete Hexith has taken a huge step
forward to make sure that America's
soldiers are able to carry weapons for
personal protection, consistent with the
Second Amendment's right to keep and
bear arms. A major statement by Pete
Hexith and the Trump administration.
Again, the Overton window continues to
expand in favor of the right to keep and
bear arms. The trend is our friend and
the Trump administration continues to be
our friend when it comes to the right to
keep and bear arms. Let's break down
this major story that is breaking now
thanks to the Secretary of War Pete
Hexith and President Trump.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Bar and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you. 2025
and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. This is a big deal. Big deal.
Another win for the Second Amendment
thanks to the presidency of Donald J.
Trump. Never say elections do not matter
because they matter big time. The
Department of War under Pete Hexith, the
Secretary, has just authorized offduty
service members to carry private
firearms on military installations. This
is basically a huge deviation, a 180
degree change from essentially what
you've had for decades and decades,
which were gun-free zones or kill zones
where America's soldiers, America's
heroes, could be killed by a wackadoodle
nut job in a so-called gun-free zone.
Well, that is no longer going to be the
case because of this announcement and
change in policy brought about by the
Trump administration and by Secretary of
War Pete Hexith. Pete Texas signed a
memorandum directing all military
military installations and their
commanders to allow war department
personnel, specifically uniform service
members, to request the right or to
request to carry privately owned
firearms while in their nonofficial duty
capacity at Department of War properties
all within the United States. This is a
huge deal, folks, according to this
press release. And I'm going to have
Pete Hexith explain exactly what this is
all about in the video that he released
just here and just now. Check it out.
Pete Hexith, the Secretary of War. Our
great republic was founded on a simple
yet bold idea. Our rights as citizens
are not granted to us by government, but
instead by God.
250 years ago, the Revolutionary War was
fought to secure our Godgiven rights.
The Second Amendment to our Constitution
enshrines the right of all citizens to
carry weapons to protect themselves,
their families, and their fellow
countrymen.
The War Department's uniform service
members are trained at the highest and
unwavering standards. These war
fighters, entrusted with the safety of
our nation, are no less entitled to
exercise their God-given right to keep
and bear arms than any other American.
Our war fighters defend the right of
others to carry they should be able to
carry themselves. Recent events like
what happened at Fort Stewart, Hollowman
Air Force Base, or Pensacola Naval Air
Station have made clear that some
threats are closer to home than we would
like. In these instances, minutes are a
lifetime, and our service members have
the courage and training to make those
precious short minutes count. Before
today, it was virtually impossible. Most
people probably don't know this, it was
virtually impossible for War Department
to get permission to carry and store
their own personal weapons aligned with
the state laws where we operate our
installations. I mean, effectively, our
bases across the country were gun-free
zones. Unless you're training or unless
you are a military policeman, you
couldn't carry, you couldn't bring your
own firearm for your own personal
protection on to post. Well, that's no
longer. The memo I'm signing today
directs installation commanders to allow
requests for personal protection to
carry a privatelyowned firearm with the
presumption that it is necessary for
personal protection. If a request is for
some reason denied, the reason for that
denial will be in writing and will
explain in detail the basis for that
direction. Again, the presumption is
service members will be able to have
their Second Amendment right on post.
Not all enemies are foreign, nor are
they all outside our border. Some are
domestic. Confirming your God-given
right to self-p protection is what I'm
signing into action today, and I'm proud
to do so.
This is fantastic news, folks. Again,
the Overton window of what is a viable
public policy choice continues to expand
in favor of the right to keep and bear
arms. Yes, we're under assault in a
handful of states that the Democrats
control. The governor's mansion, the
courts, the Senate, and the House, the
places like Colorado and Washington
State and Colorado, uh I'm sorry, and
California and New York and New Jersey
and Hawaii. You know, the usual suspect
states, "We are under attack there
because all the anti-gun money in
America is laser focused on a handful of
jurisdictions because in the rest of
America, the money should just be burned
in a fire because it won't get them
anywhere because as a general matter,
Republicans are not going to vote for
gun control anymore because among other
things, it violates the Second Amendment
right to keep him arms." But this is
great that Pete Hexith has recognized
this because of course he's recognizing
many things including the insanity
associated with gun-free zones.
Government mandated gun freeding zones
are really danger zones. This is where
nut jobs go to kill people. And that is
crazy that American soldiers and sailors
and personnel would be exposed to
madmen. And this has happened repeatedly
because again the insane people are not
so insane to realize if they want to
inflict m maximum damage maximum death
on Americans you go to where they are
defenseless. This does not take a PhD in
rocket science to figure all this out.
And of course the excellent scholarship
of Dr. John Law illustrates this point
over and over and over again that every
time we turn around and a bunch of
people have been killed by some
wackadoodle psychopathic nut job, guess
what? It's almost always in a gun-free
zone where people could not fight back.
It's also very important that Secretary
uh Hex did this because it's a reminder
that under the text the text of the
Second Amendment, the right of the
people to keep arms shall not be
infringed. The people obviously INCLUDE
ALL AMERICANS, including guess whom?
People who work for the military. People
that serve in the military. They're part
of the people as are their family
members in the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed. And they should be not be
denied the ability to protect themselves
simply because they work for the
government. It's crazy to think that.
And again, given the fact the Overton
window continues to expand in favor of
the right to carry, keep in mind that
when I was growing up, when many of you
were growing up, there's a single right
there was a single permitless carry
state. That was Vermont. And now we have
29 permitless carry states. And that
number very well could expand to North
Carolina to 30 very soon. And of course,
there's all sorts of other reasons to
think we should be happy about the right
to keep and bear arms and where it's
going in American society. Also as
further sort of details about this
change in policy involving military
personnel according to the department of
war. This is what they also note about
this new change in policy in favor of
the second amendment for our servicemen.
The memo to senior Pentagon leadership,
Defense Agency, and War Department field
activity directors titled, quote,
non-official personal protection arming
on Department of War Property states
that the new policy is consistent with
section 526 of the National Defense
Authorization Act for fiscal year 2016.
That section of fiscal year 2016 NDAA
reads that the Secretary of War may
authorize a member of the armed forces
who is assigned to duty at an
installation center or facility to carry
an appropriate firearm on the
installation center or facility if the
commander determines that carrying such
a firearm is necessary as a personal or
first or force protection measure. And
again, what's very compelling here, as
Secretary Hexis points out, the
presumption is that you get to carry the
gun. And if the comedon or the commander
of the facility, whoever is in charge
there, refuses to allow you to carry a
gun for personal protection, he has an
obligation to put in writing in detail
why he thinks it would not be
appropriate for you to be able to carry
a gun uh on that installation, on that
property, in that whatever it happens to
be. and it has to be put in writing. But
the presumption is you have a right to
keep in arms and you should be allowed
to carry and you should be given the
right to carry it on government
property. Which again, all of this is
very good news. And by the way, it's a
good reminder that the Trump
administration when it comes to
protecting our right to keep and bear
arms, it's a total force effort. It's
not just the department of justice
that's pursuing things with uh the
second amendment unit Har Dylan doing
all that work that great work at the
civil rights division. It's not just you
know the amikas brief they're fine at
the DOJ and the lawsuits they're
bringing and the challenges to like
assault weapon bans and large capacity
magazine bans across this country. It's
not just the department of justice
that's fighting for our rights for
Donald Trump. It's also here a
completely different department. the
Department of War under Pete Hexith. And
of course, in a separate story we'll
cover in more detail in a bit, the
United States Postal Service, another
part of the US government, is now
advancing the right to keep and bear
arms by virtue of allowing certain
weapons to now be shipped uh via the US
Post Office, which in the past was not
allowed. So all these different trends
are coming together to show that the
trend is our friend. And again, I'm
sorry that our friends in places like
Virginia have to suffer suffer under the
heel, the boot to the face, if you will,
metaphorically, of Democrats trying to
take away your right to keep
embarrassed. But it is a good teaching
point that you cannot let Democrats
control government because you're
essentially allowing communists that
hate Americans, hate the American way of
life, who will replace us all with
foreignb born individuals that have no
interest in preserving America as
America. all of this will occur and
Virginia illustrates the point. But on
the good news front, we have this
exciting news in favor of the Second
Amendment there in the Department of War
and we should applaud all these efforts
of the Trump administration, even if we
have specific comments and specific
criticisms and ways for them to improve.
We must realize that the trend is our
friend and we should be happy about it
as we fight this fight, we fight this
war, we fight this battle for America
every single day, which I know we do
here at the four boxes. So again, uh,
thanks for tuning in. Hope you enjoyed
today's episode. Make sure you follow me
over there on X Forboxer. We have almost
30,000 followers there. So if you can
help out, that would be great to get to
30 30,000. Don't forget to subscribe
with the YouTube and the Rumble. And
apparently there's some new thing that
you can do if you sign into YouTube.
It's called Hype Video. So to the
extent, I don't know quite know how it
works, but if you can hype this video uh
and hype my other videos, I would
appreciate it. Apparently, it's a new
thing that YouTube is rolled out. So uh,
let me know what you think about that.
if you get a moment. Okay, thanks again.
We'll talk to you again real soon here
at, you guessed it, the four box of
diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.